T'as envie qu'on mette un...
Ouais !
Film ?
Ouais, ouais...
Je... J'aime bien les films.
9 semaines et demi, tu connais ?
Ah je l'ai pas vu, mais je connais ouais.
Mais c'est génial ça, Sarah !
C'est une super idée pour un premier rencard !
Ça va bien être le malaise pendant la scène de strip-tease.
C'est le film avec la fameuse scène de strip-tease, c'est ça ?
Ouais, ouais c'est ça.
Putain et tu nous fous la honte là, avec tes prises !
Allô, Sarah ! Plus personne n'utilise de prise péritel !
Plus personne, tout le monde utilise Netflix !
Attends c'est pas la peine de s'énerver...
Ça doit juste pas être la bonne entrée...
Bah voilà.
C'était sur AV1 qu'il fallait mettre.
Oui, je suis con...
Mais non t'es pas con.
Si, si clairement t'es con !
C'est mignon.
Moi j'aime bien ce film parce que tu vois c'est pas seulement un...
Chut !
Oh le malaise !
Je suis sûre que ça bande sec !
Allez regarde, Sarah !
Juste un petit coup d'oeil.
T'en meurs d'envie.
Alors...
Ça bande ?
On peut mettre autre chose, si tu veux ?
Ah non non, j'adore le revoir ce film.
Tu m'étonnes qu'elle adore le revoir...
C'est son film de branlette !
Vas-y que je me touille la chatte sur Mickey Rourke !
Ah la la ! Mickey, c'est vachement bien !
C'est ton film préféré ?
Ouais, je l'aime bien.
Et si je reprenais la clope ?
Je vais faire la liste des points positifs et négatifs.
Alors...
Bah je tousse plus.
J'ai une très belle peau.
J'ai retrouvé le goût.
Quoi, ça va on le connait par coeur ce film.
Ouais, bah pas lui.
Un peu d'amour...
Connemara...
J'ai mon coeur qui bat normalement.
Sarah, il bat pas normalement là mon coeur !
Il bat trop vite !
Connemara !
Là-bas !
Oh bah, c'est super discret ça comme approche, Sarah !
Tu veux que je te dise un truc ?
C'est gênant.
Et ringard.
Non mais en plus regarde, il est hyper mal à l'aise le pauvre garçon.
Je te mets mal à l'aise ?
Non, non pas du tout.
Bah non, bien sûr qu'il va pas le dire !
Non, non je suis pas mal à l'aise enfin c'est plutôt...
"Je suis pas mal à l'aise..."
Il est là comme un con avec sa crête !
Putain, mais t'es vraiment qu'une sale pute d'enculé de ta mère la salope !
Eh bah niquel !
Non mais niquel !
Eh bah tu veux savoir ce que t'es toi ?
Vas-y !
Sarah.
Toi t'es la pire des connasses d'enculée de pute que la terre aie connu !
Super ! Eh bah toi...
Sarah !  Sarah !  Sarah !
Écoute, je vais y aller... Je suis désolé...
Ah bon déjà ?
Ouais j'ai des trucs à faire et...
Et pis je crois pas que c'était le bon moment...
C'est pas grave tu sais.
Non mais si, je suis vraiment désolée...
On se voit bientôt ?
Ouais, ok.
Est-ce que tu penses que la prochaine fois qu'on se voit, on pourrait se voir...
Tous les deux.
Enfin je veux dire... sans ta soeur ?
Carrément.
Cool.
Yes.
Ah parce que là on va regarder jusqu'à la fin, en fait ?